-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden
and Chinese President Xi Jinping
agreed yesterday
to reestablish
military communications.
It's what Biden is calling
the greatest
US-China collaboration
since "Rush Hour."
[ Laughter ]
Needed that one
to go well tonight
'cause he's on the show.
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that President Biden will sign
a continuing resolution
to keep the government funded
through January 19th.
So now we can finally
put this all behind us,
and also in front of us.
[ Laughter ]
After he challenged a witness
testifying before
a Senate committee yesterday
to a physical fight,
Oklahoma Senator
Markwayne Mullin
told Fox News
he was representing
"Oklahoma values."
Though based on his behavior,
I have to assume Oklahoma values
is a dollar store
outside of Tulsa.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, there's a lot of fights
at Oklahoma Valuez.
[ Laughter ]
After he challenged
the president
of the Teamsters union
to a fight,
Oklahoma Senator
Markwayne Mullin
discussed his combat strategy
with reporters yesterday
and said, "In a fight,
I'm gonna bite.
I'll do anything.
I'm not above it.
And I don't care
where I bite, by the way."
So, you're definitely
threatening to bite his penis.
[ Laughter ]
Even Jeffrey Dahmer is like,
"This guy is unwell."
[ Laughter ]
Embattled New York
Congressman George Santos
announced today that he
will not seek re-election.
However, he asked voters
to consider
casting their ballot
in the next election
for Georgina Diablos.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In a new interview,
Disney CEO Bob Iger said
the company is developing
a third "Frozen" movie
and added there might be
a "Frozen 4" in the works, too.
Kind of surprising
for a franchise
whose signature song is
"Let It Go."
[ Laughter ]
A production company in London
announced this week
a musical based on
actress Gwyneth Paltrow's
skiing collision trial
will open next month.
"We should go," said someone
halfway through the first act.
[ Laughter ]
[whispering]
This was a bad idea.
We should go.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced yesterday
that the Beast's Library
attraction at Disneyland
will permanently close
next month.
Wow!
Closing a Disney attraction
and a library --
that's like
Ron DeSantis' best day.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
CBS this week announced
that it's canceling its show
"Young Sheldon."
Man! And just after Fox canceled
"Old Sheldon."
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
We're off and running.